to us Millennials Mila Kunis will
forever be synonymous with Jackie from
That 70s Show or the voice of Meg from
Family Guy both were definitely key
fixtures of my own TV viewing hours as a
team since then she's gone on to star in
major Blockbuster films like Black Swan
Forgetting Sarah Marshall Ted and most
recently the luckiest girl alive if you
haven't watched it yet trigger warning
in advance it is a lot but on a brighter
note she's also married to one of the
hottest men of all time you know it's
both personal and sentimental diamonds
which is like totally a love story 14
years in the making it is like so cute
it hurts but have you ever wondered what
one of the most beautiful and talented
actresses eats in a day Harper's Bazaar
get at me hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at everything that Mila Kunis eats in a
day and you can pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
general disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it is not supportive
to your journey and guys if you are not
already subscribed we love to see you
guys return please hit that subscribe
button and don't forget to ring the bell
so you never miss out on a video and
also follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram over at Abby's kitchen now
before we get too far into this let me
tell you what my sponsor match Masters
if I ever needed proof that I was
becoming my mother it's that I'm low-key
obsessed with online puzzle games my new
favorite is matchmasters which is a
competitive puzzle with over 10 million
players for Apple and Android they have
various game modes including playing
against another player from around the
world along with tournaments to win
prizes and join teams it's a really
colorful interactive matching game where
you connect the like colors and shapes
to win I don't know about you guys but
between motherhood and my job my days
are super long and those 30 minutes of
alone time before bed are sacred I just
kind of need something mindless kind of
fun and satisfyingly competitive to put
me in a good mood before bed honestly
just like my mom but I also know my mom
and I are not alone like who doesn't
love a matching game app right now you
can get a 10 pinata pack with coins
boosters stickers outfits and a Lucky
Spin for free by downloading
matchmasters from the link in my
description or using the QR code on the
screen so don't forget to download
matchmasters using the link below
alright well let's get eating the first
thing I eat when I wake up is coffee but
I do have a very specific way that I
like my coffee oh but it's gonna make me
sound like whatever I like drip coffee
like old school drip coffee nothing
fancy but my creamer I'm very specific
about I like the vanilla silk oatmeal
creamer oh yes talk coffee to me bestie
I am here for it as I always say
everyone's coffee ritual is sacred so
this is a judgment-free Zone and also
those Silk coffee creamers slap I've yet
to encounter the oatmeal cookie flavor
so I will be definitely on the hunt for
that when I get down south this year but
I do get asked a lot of questions about
whether or not it's okay to drink coffee
on an empty stomach when you first wake
up and like most things it really
depends if the concern is gut irritation
or like the runs it may depend on the
type of coffee where drip coffee tends
to be a little bit more triggering than
a shot of espresso and it may also
depend on the unique sensitivity of your
gut as for the concern that drinking it
will spike your stress hormone cortisol
levels when you first wake up again this
will depend on your unique sensitivity
to stress and your tolerance to caffeine
ultimately though as I discussed in my
coffee video out right here any effect
that caffeine may have on cortisol
levels seems to diminish with regular
caffeine consumption so if you always
have your coffee in the morning your
body basically adjusts and it learns
like hey that's not bear coming at me
it's just like a frothy cup of Joe we're
gonna be okay so I don't eat first thing
in the morning I have coffee at 6 30.
take the kiddos to school whatever do
that whole thing I'm back at 8 30. I
probably eat around 9 9 30. so I don't
get the sense that waiting a few hours
to eat for breakfast is intentional
restriction or part of like an
intermittent fasting regimen it sounds
to me like Mila is just like a busy mom
focused on Surviving the morning chaos
of like getting her kiddos fed and
getting them out the door before taking
a moment to herself to enjoy her
breakfast in peace I get it I've been
there I am literally there this is my
exact routine right now literally for no
other reason that this is just what
works in my life we know that eating
while stressed or in a hurry three can
negatively impact digestion by
increasing bloating and gas likely due
to swallowing air or not thoroughly
chewing our food so if waiting a few
hours to have a more mindful breakfast
is what she needs to do to get a meal in
and to promote proper digestion then we
love to see it typical breakfast
sometimes is The Leftovers that my
children didn't eat from the morning and
I have this thing against wasting food
and so I'll eat like their leftovers
which isn't always satiating so I'll
always finish it off with like avocado
toast that I make myself I'm sorry do we
have the same life because this is
literally me most days I feel like a bit
of a human vacuum just like scarfing up
whatever snotty scraps my kids left but
to ensure my needs are still being met I
also try to make something just for me
even if it's really super easy and quick
when I make my own avocado toast I like
to make sure to grab bread that I have
so whatever I have is what we're using
and a lot of times
um it's something healthy because again
I have children and so you try to do as
much as you can so it's like a Dave's
Killer Bread right like we have one of
those and so it'll be like some whole
grain bread with like nuts and things
and texture and crunch gorgeous gorgeous
girls eat their carbs without a big
lecture about it and Dave's Killer Bread
is an awesome Choice with five grams
each of protein and fiber plus some
heart healthy omega-3 fats so it's
definitely hunger crushing combo
approved I also love that Mila chooses
this bread not because it's like gluten
free or clean or low carb but simply
because it's a nutrient dense choice to
feed her family and it has a delicious
texture and crunch that she enjoys
um I then grab my avocado I cut it I'll
smash it and then sometimes I like to
put a little everything but the bagel
seasoning and then if I'm feeling extra
feisty I might put an egg on it we love
this we got fat in the avocado protein
in the egg fiber rich carbs in the bread
and on days when Mila isn't feeling so
like feisty some alternative ways to
boost the protein content here would be
to add some pumpkin seeds hemp hearts
white beans or cottage cheese but I'll
do like two eggs over easy and then I'll
do like a piece of toast and then I'll
put like little dips on them and
sometimes it's hummus and sometimes I I
like taziki I love this it's flavorful
it's fun balanced and super easy to
prepare I go grab something to eat like
a fruit or a string cheese but more time
than not I don't have that time fruit
and string cheese are both great
handheld grab-and-go snacks and when
combined together they make an amazing
hunger crushing combo and like Mila a
lot of us are still working from home
and time often just kind of like seems
to pass Us by when we're balls deep in a
deadline or back-to-back Zoom calls but
at the same time you're not you when
you're hungry you Snickers
better
so before I sneak away to my workstation
I always make sure to bring up like a
handful of easy snacks so a build bar a
bag of nuts a few pieces of fruit
whatever it is make it easy and
accessible so that it doesn't require
extra mental work it may also be helpful
to like set an alarm on your phone as a
reminder to have a snack or your lunch
or even to stand up and give yourself a
stretch it does the mind and the body a
lot of good and we deserve to make
nourishing ourselves a priority now my
husband and I are working in at home and
so if one of us doesn't have an
afternoon something or other the other
one grabs food for the other person so
we'll miss match something together out
of the fridge and that is what you call
couple goals and my preteen crush on
Ashton Kutcher just like grew tenfold
gentlemen take note leftovers Let It Be
or something small and quick even like a
protein smoothie there's like a service
that comes and delivers smoothies to
your house pours in like a non-dairy
milk for me
um and then a protein powder it's
probably not healthy if you're a
dietitian but sometimes I I have a
protein smoothie for lunch I don't know
what dietitian she's following me on
Tick Tock but this dietitian thinks
that's actually a great option I think
smoothies are a very versatile and
efficient source of easy nutrition
especially when we're in a pinch and
don't have a lot of time to prepare and
eat a sit-down meal the key for me is to
make sure that we're getting some fiber
rich carbs protein and some healthy fats
in there if it is going to be a meal
ultimately any nutrition is good
nutrition in my books even if it's in
liquid form however it's worth noting
that smoothies are often a little less
satiating compared to chewable meals
even if they are calorically equal and
made up of the exact same components and
this is because liquids just kind of
move through our digestive system a lot
faster than Whole Foods because they
basically are pre-digested before you
consume them so if you find that they
don't hold you as long as like a
chewable meal try pairing your smoothie
with a quickie protein bar a handful of
nuts or a few samples of crackers and
cheese sometimes I do something I call
like Bowl night where it's like make
your own bowl and I do like two bases
and there'll be like a salad base and a
grain base like quinoa and then I'll
just chop up a bunch of vegetables and
cook a bunch of stuff and and then you
make your own
um vegetable my kid is a pescetarian she
does not eat meat it's oftentimes much
easier for me just to do a fish and a
healthy meal throughout the week I love
this family style meal it's low fuss
nutritionally balanced and gives
everyone autonomy to assemble their own
meal and eating family or buffet style
is actually a principle of the division
of responsibility which I discuss in my
video on how to raise an intuitive eater
right here research suggests that eating
family style promotes positive eating
behaviors like self-regulation because
children have more control and
Independence and autonomy over their
eating experience and this ultimately
allows them to trust their innate body
wisdom and maintain their innate
intuitive eating skills there's a
service that I use guys you can pick
like two meals two dinners a night or
whatever and they send you all the
groceries for said meal with like a
recipe so I do that twice a night or
twice a week so once a week she drops
off food at our house and it's always
like you know unbelievable food that my
mom makes I get my fresh veggies and my
fresh food from
um imperfect food for instance is one of
them or Misfit Market is another one for
my father-in-law gifted me like
salmon and cod that's freshly caught
from Alaska and then we have like this
amazing fish for a year or half a year I
think meal kits and delivery services
are a great way to like help streamline
the whole Grocery and cooking process if
that is something that's accessible to
you it's a huge Time Saver and can also
be a great way to reduce food waste
while also alleviating a lot of the
mental load of having to think up new
recipes to prepare for the family every
single night and having a supportive
family Network around doesn't hurt
either it really does take a village
Russian meals is like a lot of food just
at all times the obvious you can start
with Premiere you can start with
then you can do borscht which is like a
very Russian soup also made of beets the
Russians like smoked fish or fish in
general pickled fish smoked fish
Russians they like to pickle things so
we we pickle everything my mom's a
master Pickler but my mom man she can
make a chicken soup there is something
about her chicken soup all right to be
more specific chicken broth the broth of
her chicken soup is unlike anything that
I've ever been able to recreate there's
something so special about a meal that
is not only made with love but also
connects you with your cultural identity
this is also a perfect example of why
food is so much more than just calories
and nutrients it has such a strong
emotional component that allows us to
connect with loved ones through food and
honor our cultural roots and according
to the literature honoring our cultural
foods and traditions is essential to
health and well-being so I think it's
amazing that Mila is getting some
delicious home-cooked Russian meals from
her mom and sharing her cultural foods
with her kids and Fridays I like to say
it's leftover day and so my husband has
to it's just it's uh everything but the
kitchen sink meal we also do like a
clear out the fridge meal before our
next batch of groceries comes in it's a
great way to just reduce a lot of food
waste which obviously seems to be
something that Mila values also I just
have to say that this is easily one of
the most refreshing and relatable food
diary episodes I have watched to date
she's not trying to sell us on a
celebrity diet full of green juices and
kale salads or smoothies from erwan or
extravagant meals made with specialty
ingredients she does what she can with
what she has on hand and the time that's
available to her and she isn't afraid to
take shortcuts and call on her family
members for support we eat dinner all as
a family oh we order out from everywhere
I love to order food that I don't make
for instance I don't make sushi I will
order out sushi I don't do Thai I will
order out Thai I don't do Indian I will
order out Indian we just did just get a
pizza oven so we made our own pizzas for
the first time my daughter puts
pineapple on olives cheese and tomato
sauce my son likes tomato sauce and a
very light amount of cheese my husband
does mushrooms jalapenos and olives on
his cheese tomato sauce DIY pizza is a
great family meal that allows kids to
get involved in the kitchen the more
autonomy they have over choices like
toppings the more like likely they are
to try it and you're not short order
cooking to each kid's unique meal
preferences everyone has the same meal
they just kind of get to choose what
goes on it oh my beverage of choice it's
water because it's healthy for you my
honest beverage of choice is a glass of
wine relatable but the whole family now
loves Poppy
okay poppy beverages anybody here poppy
lollipop I feel like it's because it
says Prebiotic and micro clearly this is
this is healthy I don't know if it is or
isn't but boy do I like a nice little
puppy first off if she likes poppy
regardless of the health claims then
that is reason enough to continue to
enjoy it as for the Prebiotic claims
poppy beverages get their Prebiotic
Boost from apple cider vinegar which
contains the Prebiotic pectin which is
naturally found in a variety of fruits
including apples but one we don't
actually know how much apple cider
vinegar is in this drink probably not a
lot of it or it would just taste like
straight up vinegar and two you can
actually obtain far more Prebiotic
pectin from eating a single Apple than
you can from drinking a tablespoon of
apple cider vinegar but again if Mila
and the whole family love poppy then by
all means just keep enjoying it but at
the end of the day you're better off
getting your Prebiotic thicks from some
fruits and veg after dinner the children
are always they're always allowed like
to have a bite of something sweet and
then my husband and I open the freezer
and have ice cream every night oh girl
what kind of ice cream we have so much
ice cream people know I love ice cream
and so for my birthday they send me like
ice cream of the month clubs or like
some sort of variety we have so much we
always have ice cream I love ice cream
my kids love ice cream
um my husband loves ice cream it's my
favorite food group we have eaten at I
would say every ice cream place in Los
Angeles I swear this woman is my soul
mate and again having a nighttime ice
cream ritual with your hubby especially
when that hubby is Ashton Kutcher is
Major couples goals because I too always
have a ton of ice cream in the house so
I love this little tidbit overall I
think this is one of the most relatable
food Dyers episodes I've ever watched it
wasn't overly curated or trying to
promote an unattainable celebrity
lifestyle I mean Mila really just kept
it super real and wasn't afraid to say
hey I'm a busy working mom who is doing
my best to feed my family and myself
sometimes that means eating like scraps
off of my family's plate so please let
this serve as a reminder to all the
working parents out there who feel like
they need to do it all or feel like they
are always failing it is absolutely okay
to lean on kitchen Time Savers or ask
for support from family and friends for
most of us it's not realistic to prepare
every meal from scratch while also
raising a family and working full-time
and I think Mila is a great example of a
super mom who has found a way to do the
things that bring her Joy without
putting too much pressure on herself to
do them perfectly and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video please give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what he'd like to see me
review next subscribe to this Channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]